hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba who's
you is Lauren Francesca eyes Lauren
Francesca Lauren is back visiting from
Texas yes it is so nice isn't it Lauren
say since you're back in town with us
really quick I want to tell you guys to
go check out where do you mainly want
people to follow you want to get this
out of the way I want my Lauren put my
link in your description whatever link
you want oh my all the links to me go
narrow down your links are so at our
patreon we have a topper war to your
video requests here whatever video
requested was doing put up on YouTube
this is a random one comes from a man
named Mikhail Linden he's a beautiful
Swedish bastard
it's called drunk people fails Wow so
it's just a compilation awesome I know
other reacting channels have covered
drunk people fails but have you seen one
myself let's see
[Music]
oh my gosh no man
oh why does she do it oh that hurt no
[Music]
dude oh dude you could like kill
yourself all these girls
[Music]
was he drunk I don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh no something Bad's gonna happen
now what is she doing now I'm scared for
her the sherry room if she this is scary
oh these people doing have you never
been this drunk I mean this is why I'm
sober right now in this moment what is
this Oh No ow oh dude you could like
really something what do they do
is she yeah I'm glad those were two
girls even how you could get a
concussion what are they doing these
people
you can get it what is he doing he broke
the table we're responsible adults and
we're thinking about finances Wow Wall
Street guys oh god no don't eat those
don't eat them don't do it no I like
that accent what is that it's wind Oh
what there
[Music]
[Music]
feel so bad for her your laugh aid this
poor girl she probably just got dumped
in don't really know those her boyfriend
she was talking Oh God what's gonna
happen now what is this girl doing I'm
scared for her what - Gabby she'll oh
she's sitting on someone's card and I
had no idea what she was doing
shake it off oh that's so funny where is
this where does it ring oh wow
you like drowned in the rain
[Music]
[Music]
I feel bad that these people are
actually getting hurt Oh nose foots
caught oh please don't kick the kid
[Music]
oh I would be really angry
oh that's property damage Oh God
you know like no drunk incident is funny
enough to me
where if you cause property damage on my
property that I'm gonna be like whatever
it was funny there's nothing you can do
that was really scary boy gonna get you
repaired for Halloween there Lauren yeah
do you ever the first time you got drunk
yeah like you really remember I remember
my first time you do yeah this is me
segwaying into me telling you my story
of the first time I got drunk I don't
think you noticed that have you heard of
an actor named Steven McQueen yes he was
in The Vampire Diaries in piranhas have
you met him no haven't you met him I
knew him before he was ever like famous
so I used to be like anti-drinking anti
smoking anti everything and we were
staying at my friend's place for
house-sitting and he was like dude Greg
I'm gonna get you drunk I'm like I want
you to Queen yeah heep-ha doesn't
remember his number no I don't know him
anymore it's so long least the decades
he likes it again I met his dad once let
me finish my store so cool famous people
hood so he brought over a bottle of
vodka and it was on top of a hill by the
Jerry's deli in Sherman Oaks I had I
think I counted 15 shots of vodka
keep in mind I'd never been drunk by
this point so I take the 15 shots super
quick
I feel nothing I feel like I'm a total
man because I'm like I've never been
tipsy or anything I'm like I feel
nothing we started walking down the hill
to go get some food and it hits me like
this way this ocean waves absolutely I'm
[ __ ] blaster yeah Jerry's deli
I'm belligerently drunk we start walking
back I'm crying about something you know
like wailing and tears and then I wake
up and my other buddy who crashed there
that night I woke up like naked with a
photo of my friend's mom and a bottle of
ocean but they just put that
[Laughter]
did you think no I was like yeah I
wouldn't go that far
I don't care how drunk I was I did it no
no no wasn't his mom wasn't his Homer at
the time but yeah that was my first time
getting drunk it was a good time that
was and yeah that's fun
the biggest fail I ever had was falling
through my 30k subscriber party I got so
wasted first 30 minutes of that party
everyone else had a great time
crashed I wasn't present for any of it
because I'm not and they took photos of
me just not bad you have those on your
Instagram those are deleted I was really
upset that they did that and I was
jealous but other than that I've never
cause like property damage or anything
like that have you oh you know gosh I
tell a long story you're way worse on
Elmo and was that a VidCon one of the
the CEOs of a really big youtube network
I get into his uber we're going back to
the hotel was outside of the the window
I always make sure it's like not in the
car I was so I was so drunk and then he
like hit me up and he's like Lauren I
had to pay $100 cleaning fee I was just
like I'm so sorry was so embarrassing
and that's why I don't drink anymore
how long ago was this okay
enough time has passed instead oh geez
it was embarrassing though I would guys
first that girl at VidCon who did that
he said you'd be paid for it though yeah
okay hey Jim good tip no no I mean it
was the guy it was the my friends uber
so I sent my friends $100 Oh is your
friends okay Oh big CEOs uber
oh gosh oh that just felt really bad
that is embarrassing have you lost touch
with your friend
yeah was it because of that maybe
possibly yeah well I hope your friends
watching now Oh God will these people
here in this video oh there is something
really amusing about watching it is
actually know in person I do get
concerned like I want my girlfriend to
we're on the downtown la strip let's do
some movie and then there's some girl
who just like fell hard on the sidewalk
drunk it just like slammed her her
tailbone on the sidewalk and people
laughed and I was like oh my god she all
right that is awful and she hit her
tailbone then she slipped and slammed
her head too and people just laughed at
her and I'm like that's not funny yeah
that's not funny but when I watch it in
a video format it is really funny I
don't know why in real life it's like
the way gun violence isn't me like real
a hoop and the movies cool this ain't
even like drunk people immediately yeah
that's funny you in real life I do get
very concerned I just never thought that
balcony that broke I'm just I'm wearing
it's that guy okay
oh see my mind goes to how much is that
gonna cost
yeah guy thoughts they're costing a lot
of money that yeah yeah and they went
yeah when they went through the offense
that's a lot of money yeah anyway tell
us in the comments your most
embarrassing drunk fail make sure to
follow Lauren on all those links that
are in the pin comment you guys can
subscribe for the real rejects I don't
really cover videos like this but we did
today click that notification Val and
Mikhail Linden thanks so much for
sending this over dude hey Lauren yeah
it's where we have such a delightful
female presence to shout out Mikael in a
video can you just give him a Cale a
little shout-out to give him something
new he's Swedish loves James Bond to say
something McCarroll I love Swedish guys
who love James Bond and Greg showed me
your picture and you're really hot love
you account oh my god you're the perfect
Bond girl for